les voici un tableau de famille l'époque
14e siècle le lieu la france
le roi philippe iv
la france est alors le plus puissant des
royaumes d'occident
le roi a une réputation de beauté
légendaire qui ça colle à son nom il est
il restera philippe le bel
auprès de lui
ses trois fils tous trois majeurs louis
de navarre dit le hutin ou si vous
voulez le dispute heures le confus
philippe conte de poitiers et charles de
france
leurs épouses respectives se tiennent au
deuxième rang marguerite fille du duc de
bourgogne
derrière le hutin sont marie jeanne
héritière de la comté de bourgogne qui
sera plus tard la franche-comté derrière
philip son époux et enfin blanche sa
soeur cadette marié à charles de france
ces deux dernières sont les filles de
maraude artois veuve du comte palatin de
bourgogne car il y a deux bourgogne le
duché la comté mahaut d'artois la voici
au plus haut rang il y à 12 pairs du
royaume
elle est l'un d'eux lé comtesse père
d'artois son neveu robert aisé à
reconnaître c'est un homme écarlate du
pur point jusqu'aux bottes il est
couleur de sang est le sien est généreux
tous descendent au 2e 3e ou 4e degrés du
roi louis 9 ou de son père ils sont la
race de saint louis
voici encore les deux frères du roi le
bouillant charles compte de valois
compte de romagne il est aussi empereur
titulaire de constantinople et lesage
louis comte d'evreux
le reste n'est pas d'aussi haut lignage
il y a là des grands serviteurs de
l'état
le coadjuteur du royaume enguerrand de
marigny le garde des sceaux guillaume de
nogaret quelques barons conseiller
évêques et un banquier lombard spinelle
l'autonomie qui d'un oeil surveille les
affaires du royaume
pour philippe le bel la grandeur de la
france primes tout il a découragé tous
ses ennemis extérieurs à l'intérieur
aucune richesse n'échappe à sa main
dévaluation des monnaies spoliation des
fortunes impôts écrasant tout doit
s'incliner plier ou rompre devant
l'autorité royale
il a même fait élire un pape français
qui l'installé de force en avignon mais
l'idée nationale loge dans la tête de ce
prince impassible et cruel pour qui la
raison d'état domine toutes les autres
un seul pouvoir avait osé lui tenir tête
l'ordre souverain des chevaliers du
temple
cette colossale organisation à la fois
militaires religieux et financière
devait aux croisades dont elle était
issue sa gloire et sa richesse
philippe le bel a fait instruire contre
le temple le plus vaste procès dont
l'histoire gardera mémoire 15000 inculpé
sept ans de procédure de torture d'un
famille enfin cette blonde princesse un
peu à l'écart c'est isabelle épouse d'
edward ii d'angleterre
la seule fille de philippe le bel on
l'appellera plus tard la louve de france
elle est une reine triste de l'autre
côté de la manche
regardez robert d'artois a quitté sa
place
il s'apprête à la rejoindre il est en
route pour westminster
[Musique]
oh
à temps
et
m
[Musique]
il
à
d'amour ne doit plus dire bien car je
n'en ai ni peut ni rien car je n'en ai
ni peut rien de touchantes parole en
vérité on les croirait tout juste fait
pour moi madame madame votre fils à port
louis vraiment kelly
il a frappé datable il a dit je veux gm
ce premier mot ces paroles de roi
puisque il commence à parler je demande
qu'on encourage pas prononcé des
niaiseries comme on fait d'ordinaire
avec les autres enfants seraient aussi
lui enseigner dès qu'il pourra
l'entendre qu'il est de france autant
que d'angleterre et vous direz chaque
soir devant lui la prière au roi saint
louis mon aïeul monseigneur robert
d'artois
alors
messire mon cousin avez-vous fait bonne
traversée exécrable madame horrifique
une tempête à rendre les tripes et l'âme
j'ai cru ma dernière heure venue
si bien que je me suis mis à confesser
mes péchés à dieu par chance il n'y en
avait si grand nombre que le temps de
dire la moitié nous étions arrivés ils
m'auraient se passer pour le retour
madame je suis nu de france tout exprès
pour vous dire que vos belles soeurs
sont des [ __ ] ce serait d'ouvrir quoi
chan est plus chaud si blanche
j'en suis assuré pour jeanne plus drori
mais pas plus d'innocence oui madame aux
trois frères sont cocus qu'occupe comme
des manants
avez-vous des noms des silhouettes les
nuits où votre frère louis de navarre
est absent la tour de nesle demeurer
clairet jusqu'au matin on en a vu sortir
des hommes qui ne sont sûrement pas des
moines et qui visiblement ne viennent
pas de chanter le salut
et puis les joyaux disparaissent de la
cassette de votre cousine marguerite qui
sont échangées jeu un banquier lombard
quand on est pogné de damas donc si ce
que vous m'annoncez sûr je ne tolérerai
pas tant n'aimerais pas que ma famille
soit objet de risée débat en france
croyez le ne supporteront pas non plus
en avez vous parlé à la bonne cousine
vous connaissez le roi philippe mieux
que je ne le connais il croit tant à la
vertu des femmes
il faudra lui montrez vos belles soeurs
voterait avec leurs galons pour qu'il
consentit à m'entendre
et puis je ne suis pas aussi bien en
cours depuis que j'ai perdu mon procès
les rois ont ce site commun et rien
d'autre avec les bourgeois que les
querelles de bornage commande parfois
leurs sentiments en tranchant en faveur
de ma tante may ou de l'attribution du
comté d'artois le roi par le mariage de
ses fils avec nous
mais [ __ ] de cousine a fait tomber le
comté bourgogne du côté de la couronne
je suis donc très important d'avoir été
dépossédés vous avez tort mon cousin je
ne sais mais précisément ne pourrait-on
pas penser que vous agissez ainsi par
vengeance mais bien sûr j'ai agi par
vengeance
la fortune de vos frères me navre comme
elle n'a avant les autres barons mais me
sert on m'a volé l'héritage de mon
compte et madame pour le donner ma tante
may ou quelques rêves de la lèpre
dumange la face vous ce que c'est qu'un
conte et moi la main ou qui étrenne ce
que c'est que le comté d'artois
c'est de la terre de la bonne terre
grasse qui colle aux mains ou les bottes
s'enfonce pourri de grêle et charogne je
la veux cette terre vous parliez de mes
belles soeurs il me semble
oui madame je me vengerai sur elle que
ce que la mère m'a fait lequel vengeance
il faut être roi pour dire justice
elle voit ici madame il me faut les noms
de ses hommes
je ne peux agir sans cela obtenez l'est
et je me rendrai à paris pour faire
cesser ce désordre alors aidez-moi
qu'elle fasse à vous aimer les épouses à
vos frères du temps
rien n'empêche couleur facile et présent
ce genre de colifichets qui conviennent
aussi bien les femmes que les hommes
des présents que vous leur ferez
parvenir secrètement sans avertir ni
dernier point je gage qui ne tardons pas
changé de mains nous verrons alors
lequel ma il s'agit et vous tiendrez les
nombres vous voulez
on m'a livré 7 aumônière ce matin voilà
bien l'objet 15 jouvence ou le coeur
devrait s'empresser d'accrocher à sa
ceinture pour se faire valoir
le major comme andré 3 semblable mon
marchand arvier vous pourrez les
importer en france à les faire tenir aux
princesses sans qu'on sache que vous
m'avez servi de messager
c'est le roi mon époux ciseaux que je
suis marié je vis dans les truelles et
dans le mortier messelyn certains
chantiers on ne cesse de défaire ce
qu'on a fait le mois d'avant le roi aime
toujours la maçonnerie pas la maçonnerie
comme le roi ce sont les maçons on le
dit aurait en effet si les barons 10,6
et les couvreurs edwards
ma belle cousine je vous servir d'appui
une reine et la plus misérable des
sujets de son royaume quand son mari ne
l'aiment points on attendait de moi
cogestion la descendance
rien d'autre pour l'heure ce sont les
barons des spencer qui ont la faveur du
roi père gouvernants hughes le fils qui
sert de femmes mon époux je suis seul
jour et nuit
ce car wade faute de connaître la
perfection d'autres et non des moindres
on remerciera le ciel je songeais ce que
je m'impose émeuvent
isabelle
non robert
je laisse mes cousines de bourgogne le
privilège de ce qu'elle appelle sans
doute le bonheur
comme vous voulez ressembler guy roy
philippe votre père
j'attendrai un message de vous pour
savoir s'il faut me mettre en route pour
la france
adieu mon cousin
aucun de ces deux au personnage ne
pouvait imaginer au terme de cette
entrevue qu'il serait par l'enchaînement
de leurs actes
les premiers artisans d'une guerre entre
la france et l'angleterre
une guerre qui durerait plus de 100 ans
[Musique]
quentin n'auront pas ce n'est pas
possible nous sommes les quatre derniers
deux peut-être fatigué le tuer et puis
une somme plus ganges entendu le frère
guy dauphin à qui il fut en juin si l'un
de ses frères supérieur était tourmenté
par la chaire et se voulait satisfaire
sur lui de consentir à tous ceux qui lui
serait demandé manceau entendu le frères
hughes de perrault qui reconnaît avoir
fait obligation aux na'vis tu auras nier
le christ par trois fois cédé rang que
les accusés ont reconnu les condamnons
onu et au silence
pour le reste de leurs jours afin qu'ils
obtiennent la rémission de leur faute
par les larmes du repenti
mes frères je n'ose y croire on ne nous
le du point tu es fou
vous avez entendu grâce on vous fait
grâce laissez vous but niçois votre
hymne soulagement vous avez obtenu ce
que n'avait pu ni les coins il maniait
ni l'étirement ni les tenailles vous
m'avez retenez l'honneur de trois je
proteste je proteste contre une sentence
inique
j'affirme devant le ciel que l'ordre est
sain et que l'ordre est innocent et a
joué la sodomie sous la torture vous
avertir tous tout le monde attend dé
vous je suis jacques de molay grand
maître du temple selon la règle reçu de
saint-bernard nous avons tous lutter
pour la garde des lieux saints de
palestine nous avons toujours respecté
la chasteté la pauvreté l'obéissance à
la guerre nous avons toujours accepté le
combat à un contre 3 et n'avons jamais
chasser d'autres bêtes que le lion
regardez moi m'avait tout prix tout
changer toute la ville jusqu'à mes gars
et l'âme par la douleur mais je me
rétracte
je démens la firme devant dieu je ne
suis coupable que d'avoir menti sous le
tournant nous sommes innocents et ceux
qui disent qu autrement ne mentais par
la bouche
deux des condamnés sont déclarés relapse
il rejette la justice de l'église
l'église les rejettent les romains la
justice du roi marguerie d'autres
hameaux vous perdez la tête mais il lui
jeunes vous êtes tous fous je ne veux
plus être mêlé à vos affaires cela
finira mal ciblage tu verras et puis je
ne veux plus me compromettre un plaisir
pour rien il tient qu'à toi que ce soit
pour quelque chose
dunod trois maris qui sortent de prison
si marguerite et moi avions cette chance
je n'en ai pas le goût ou pas le courage
il est vrai que même si je le voulais je
n'ai pas ton habilité à décibulles et je
suis sûr que je ne trahirai tout de
suite
madame vous entendez ce que dit votre
soeur on vous sait l'art de feindre
marguerite aussi en vérité votre frère
gautier est plus agréable que vous c'est
sans doute qu'il est mieux traité et
j'en suis heureux pour lui
en effet je suis un bien grand saut de
me laisser humilier par une femme qui me
traitent en valais m'appelle dans son
lit quand l'envié lui en prend
m'éloigne quand l'envié lui passe et me
laisse cinq jours sans me donner signe
de vie
est il raisonnable de se mettre en telle
peine pour 5 bonjour mes filles et bien
que contient vos dons
il faut nous pardonner cire mais nos
paroles ne sont guère aisé à vous
répéter pourquoi cela c'est que nous
disions du mal de vous en vérité qui s
damoiseaux messi redonnait écuyers de
notre oncle valoir n'avez vous pas un
frère louis cyr un frère qui est à
monseigneur de poitiers c'est cela je
vous confond toujours quel mal disiez
vous de moi jeanne et moi étions
d'accord pour vous en vouloir beaucoup
sur mon père car voici cinq nuits de
suite que nos maris ne nous son point de
service s'envoler retard aux séances du
conseil
vous les envoyez loin pour les affaires
du royaume et la troisième que dit elle
marguerite elle s'enferme elle fait son
âme noire et elle dit que vous êtes
aussi méchant que vous êtes debout
et bien rassurez marguerite et
rassurez-vous blanche
mes fils louis et charles pourront vous
tenir compagnie et ce soir aujourd'hui
est une bonne journée
le tribunal épiscopale assiégé la sphère
des templiers et effacer des soucis
public l'oeuvre de cette année
parachever il n'y aura pas de conseils
cette nuit sir le grand maître s'est
rétracté année
[Musique]
tu saoules louis lavoie chat poubelle
j'ai cru des bailleurs de père il
al'oreille la plus fine du royaume
venez rapprochons-nous des boutiques qui
t'ont ses terres de complot
[Musique]
si on enseigne le compte de poitiers qui
est en bourgogne et monseigneur charles
parti tôt pour la chasse qui n'a pu être
joint n'assisteront pas au conseil
quand mon seigneur le compte de valois
je les envoyais et guérir mais le temps
presse
commençons le grand maître de l'ordre du
temple et le précepteur normandie ont
été remis cyr entre vos mains par la
commission de l'église il vous est
désormais loisible de disposer d'eux
totalement sans en référer à personne
fût ce au pape
est ce parce que nous pouvions espérer
de mieux qu ai-je entendu cyr mon frère
messire le portier de marigny prétend
que tout va pour le mieux eh bien je me
demande quel jour vos conseillers
trouveront que tout va mal 4e vieillard
à demi moore dont on affirmait que le
sort était réglé tiennent en échec
l'autorité royale
le peuple lui hurle à la mort contre les
prélats contre les archers entre vous et
tout va pour le mieux et jouissant nous
puisque tout va au mieux mon seigneur de
valois doit être mal renseigné sûrement
moins bien que vous mais sir puisque
c'est votre frère l'archevêque qui
présidait le tribunal sur les quatre
vieillards dont par monseigneur deux
seulement ont protesté contre la
sentence qui les condamnait quant au
peuple tous les rapports m'assure qu'il
est fort partagé l'opinion partagée ces
scandales déjà qu'ils puissent être
partagés qui demande au peuple son
opinion vous messire de mariniers si les
aux barons dont vous êtes le plus haut
mon seigneur s'était soumis deux
meilleurs gré aux ordonnances royal
nous n'aurions pas eu besoin de nous
appuyer sur le peuple nous voyons
maintenant le résultat de votre nouvelle
lt vous avez cru bon d'assembler les
bourgeois les villes
un autre manne ans pour leur faire
approuver les violons du roy a par
exemple le peuple s'arrogent le droit de
juger mon frère ce ne sont point des
assemblées mais des templiers que là ce
jour nous nous occupons soit
occupons nous des templiers nogaret cyr
la choses monstrueuses qui vient de se
produire devant notre-dame prouve que
toute indulgence toute clémence accordée
à des suppôts du diable est une
faiblesse qui se retourne contre vous on
laisse assez chienpourri neuvic ils ne
méritent pas au lieu de bénir leurs
juges
il en profite aussi tout pour insulter
l'église est le roi des templiers sont
des hérétiques hérétiques vous-même
messire de nogaret n'êtes vous pas
petit-fils de qatar et naguère d'un
soufflé
n'avez vous pas fait tomber le pape
jeudi que les templiers sont des
hérétiques était en tout cas car si j'ai
bonne mémoire de quelques milliers
qu'ils se comptaient en france et que
vous avez pas ni roux et ou aux tic
il ne vous en reste que quatre hommes
assez embarrassant je vous la corde
puisque après sept ans de procédure ils
viennent encore clamé leur innocence
nous savons monseigneur que vous avez
toujours appuyé les templiers sans doute
comptiez vous sur eux pour reconquérir
fut flagrant ruine de la france se
transforme de constantinople sur lequel
il apparaît que vous ne vous a guère
incité la wii taisez vous dire mon frère
dieu m'est témoin que je n'ai jamais
changé qu'à vos intérêts à votre doigt
mon frère encore une fois c'est des
templiers qu'il s'agit se joue
je vous demande votre conseil on
conseille vous me demandez mon conseil
est bien
que ceux qui ont si bien conduit la
faire jusqu'ici vous inspire comment la
terminer à brax louis votre conseil
si l'on remettait les templiers au pape
taisez-vous louis douville
je réfléchis je réfléchis nogaret votre
conseil que ceux qui sont retombés dans
l'hérésie subisse le châtiment des
hérétiques le peuple il attend que vous
fassiez un acte droit sir le peuple
criaient ce matin pour les templiers il
se réjouir est tout autant ce soir de
leur supplice acte ii roi
n'oubliez pas mon frère que le grand
maître a rang de prince souverain
toucher à sa tête
cette attente et au respect qui protège
les rois
jacques de molay et geoffroy de charnay
seront brûlées ce soir dans l'île aux
juifs face aux jardins du palais la
rébellion a été publique
le châtiment sera public mais si on de
nogaret rédigera l'acte jeudi j'entends
que tous ici vous assistiez au supplice
ceux qui ordonnent coffre aussi regarder
que notre fils charles soit lui aussi
présent quand en avertisse
on avait
nous venons d'assister à la fin de la
chevalerie
[Musique]
on
où
l'orme et homme de confiance de
monseigneur d'artois petit vent de sud
est
le tirage se frappent les deux curés
vont griller dans l'allégresse leroy lé
prince crise que d'avoir des fumeurs à
battante s'appelera bis mais le
spectacle moi j'ai une affaire est
expédié un homme de confiance quand ça
n'est pas comme le guen on est vite
tenté d'en faire un homme de main
[Musique]
il
béni soit les deux hérétiques sans eux
nous ne serions pas là soir quitte a
prévenu jane comme toujours
alors ils sont beaux ils sont chan sans
parfumée tu n'as rien surpris qui vaille
un mot qui leur auraient échappé à tout
est prêt oui regardez mon seigneur
l'hôtel donnell la lumière dans la tour
tout est bien
[Musique]
c'est comme le premier jour
je n'arriverais jamais y croit chan
tadic blanche voulait bien oui
marguerite est choisi pour amant il
suffit de voir et de regarder le 8 mai
mort d'un lit mais blanche
pourquoi moi son mari est beau il a
toutes les apparences du roi et ne même
pas d'amour
le même pour imiter sa cousine
[Musique]
et
et bien qu as-tu mon beau fils y es-tu
pas heureux ne vois je le suis madame
encore une nouvelle parure quel est le
nouveau galant c'est pour me narguer
sans doute que tu que tu es jeune et que
tu me plais
je crois que c'est un présent d'amour
[Musique]
je te la donne maintenant son état
marguerite les spams pris dans ce que tu
fais là
non personne ne sait de qui c'est une
manière nous viennent nous avons jamais
porté c'est efira d'avertir jeunes alors
je ne veux pas que mon bel amant soit
moins aimé et moi pareil chrétiens
[Musique]
étant pliée
les emmène au bûcher
blanche gauthier venez voir se bouge pas
je suis trop bien pouvoir et du ska
louer là bas et que se faisait jour il
pourra nous voir écoute
s'envoler
et vont griller et nous pond un instant
am a tué sa femme en chevalier blanc
les moustiques à comparaître au tribunal
le quai ok vous serez tous nos maux qui
jusqu'à la génération plus vraiment trop
eh bien mon frère nous voilà content je
pense non mon frère je ne le suis point
j'ai commis une erreur
vraiment vous en convenez aurait dû leur
faire arracher la langue avant de les
brûler
c'est tout de même étrange une barque ne
se détache pas tout seuls quelques à
l'heure à police pour aller au supplice
eh bien il faudra marcher jusqu'au pont
ce n'est pas payé cher pour le plaisir
que nous venons de prendre
tu vois la campagne aurait put alors on
ne sait plus son métier mais les voleurs
tu apprends ça toi décidément on a
raison de dire qu'il ya police non plus
d'ailleurs
pendant qu'on assassine les sergents de
mes séries nogaret pas blessé j'espère
non mais il était temps sans votre
secours
monseigneur par le diable mais je vous
reconnais aussi mesdames oiseaux les
frères donnait
les plus jolis garçons de la cour du
diable si je m'attendais l'enseignement
nous ne saurions vous assurez d'assez de
grandeur petite affaire petites gens
petits moyens
heureusement vous étiez là pour relever
la partie à deux certes vous étiez un
peu en faiblesse mais dès lors que nous
étions 3 je suis bien aise d'avoir
conservé mes cousins de valois et
poitiers leurs meilleurs écuyers mais
dites moi dans mes lames oiseaux que
faisiez-vous par le diable dans ce sens
je réduis nous nous promenions
monseigneur vous promener à cette heure
en ce lieu avec de la boue jusqu'aux
fesses roche jeunesse toujours en quête
d'amour et l'autre chaux sans feu matin
bel ornement
et vous aussi pour maîtresse censeurs
parole et de bien aux dames sans nul
doute et bien généreuse
monseigneur se trompe c'est bourse nous
viennent de familles à deux familles
deux familles bonbons on se taira pour
l'honneur de vos belles
je vous approuve mais damoiseaux les
dames qu'on baise il faut en respecter
la renommer dieu vous assistent les
frères données vous pouvez compter sur
mon amitié à un conseil ne vous promenez
plus de nuit avec toute cette joaillerie
réservé là où soleil de la cour le crois
tu capable de fermer sa large gueule je
pense ce n'est pas un méchant gaillard
et son sa large gueule comme tu dis nous
aurions déjà plus de ce monde mais que
faisait-il là a par ailleurs ils
cherchaient des rebound les bordeaux ne
manquent pas aux rives de la seine bon
je sais à présent ce que je voulais
savoir qui est le chef mois
partagez-vous mais flanqué un rude coup
mon seuil est pas été compris dans le
marché
belle affaire lors mecque le cul des
filles on peut y trouver raconté 2000
livres
est ce là une somme au comptant elle ne
convient j'aimerais donc que les choses
puissent régler au plus vite
mille dans chacun voudrait bien
renseigné me signer cette décharge
j'aimerais mieux que ces reliques ne
soit pas vendu enfants smith le vote
soit monseigneur nos hommes sont aux
pattes
je ne suis pas fou comme on dit dans mon
pays non je voulais dire est ce bien
nécessaire d'indiquer la provenance de
ces objets pour vous moucher rires
quelle importance nul d'autre que moi ne
verra cette décharge ma profession a
ceci de commun avec votre sacerdoce
qu'elle exige le secret vous confesser
les armes nous confessons les bourses
dieu seul sait ce qui est le plus grave
pour l'acquéreur étranger savoir d'où
tout cela provient épreuves de bon
endroit
on savait les templiers à visée on a
fait ce ne sont pas bons ce ne sera pas
trop d'où j'ai mes serviteurs un bas on
va vous aider à monseigneur savez vous
comment le roi dieu le préserve a reçu
mes chiens un lièvre que je lui ai
envoyé entière commencé de vous que lui
vient ce grand lévriers qui ne le quitte
plus et qu'elle appelle lombard il
appelait lombard que je suis content de
l'apprendre leroy notre sierra vient de
l'esprit à mon neveu
guti au bal you and i nouvellement est
arrivé de sienne tu va reconduire mon
seigneur de marigny et l'aider à porter
ceci jusqu'à la rue c'est que mon nom
qui lie à la dent monseigneur robert
d'artois qui demandent à être reçus je
préférerais ne pas le rencontrer
certes certes monseigneur d'artois est
un grand parleur tu veux dire à ce que
monseigneur l'archevêque ne rencontre
personne
[Musique]
quand je pense que ces fonds serviront à
fournir votre inépuisable charité j'en
arrive à envier vos pauvres
ryan a ni de voleurs
mais avant tout couillon
[Musique]
e
alors mon seigneur besoin de moi oui
deux choses à vous demander la première
gym agissait de larges juriez de
métriques
est ce que tout un chacun doit savoir
que je boudais fortune alon kozé dans
votre cabinet où nous parlons d'abord de
la seconde chose sinon je gage que vous
feriez la faute de me refuser la
première à
alors vous devez être bien contents ce
matin pourquoi mon seigneur tout de même
les templiers
euh oui non monseigneur autonome et qui
vous a annoncé voici sait-on que les
templiers allait être piégé comme lapin
en carène qui vous a conseillé de leur
faire quelques solides emprunts que vous
leur rendrai jamais à présent allons
dans remarquer remarquez que je
comprends fort bien que vous disiez oui
et non vous êtes de ceux voulait manquer
lombard qui avait prêté de l'argent au
roi et notre bon roi philippe était
aussi débiteurs des juifs des templiers
ils les arts outils les uns après les
autres et vous êtes troisième de l'iss
il se pourrait que je ne soit bientôt
plus sur la liste du tout et comment
cela
la france m'a généreusement accueillis
je pourrai remettre les dettes du roi de
france
l'eau coule avec la dette que je ne
rembourserait pas aux templiers
précisément je ne vous dis tout cela mon
seigneur pour vous montrer que je fait
bon usage de vos informations même si je
n'en tiens pas toujours un bénéfice qui
nous pas dans vos affaires
cette fois je tiens ma tante now oh j'ai
déjà entendu cela quand vous avez fait
procès à votre tante pour l'héritage du
comté de thouars et perdu le procès moi
j'ai payé les frais en vraie justice je
devrais être père du royaume est le plus
riche baron de france et je le ferai
vous m'entendez tholot mail je le serai
en attendant elle vous après lyon encore
de l'argent pour entretenir vos
partisans en artois et que frêche sans
mes amis c'est grâce à eux que je
gagnerais mac os un jour et les armes à
la main s'il le faut pour aujourd'hui je
vous ai dit que je tiens ma au je la
tiens parce que je tiens ces filles et
sa cousine
et que je vais les étrangler cac comme
de malfaisants de belette vous les tenez
mais encore les petites kata ont des
amants même à moi mon seigneur vous ne
le prenez pas oui mais moi depuis cette
nuit
moi je sais les noms en quoi cela
peut-il vous servir me servir autant
l'homme et la future reine de france à
ses belles soeurs pincer comme des
ribaudes les deux familles de bourgogne
plonger dans cette grotte jusqu'à la
gueule que vous faut-il de plus mao
perdre tout crédit à la cour les
mariages sont dissous les héritages
s'évanouissent et les espoirs de la
couronne aussi alors je retiens la
reprise de mon procès cette fois je le
roi de mon côté et je le gagne
c'est vous qui allez tous révélés au roi
mois il m'entendrai pas non quelqu'un
quelqu'un qu'il me faut faire venir
attendez vous de moi un homme sûr et peu
voyant aussi hors de prix offert voilà
l'angleterre porter un message à qui mon
seigneur la remise appel et pourquoi
envoyer ou pas un homme avoue bien un
chercheur de monseigneur de valois parce
que dans nos maisons proches de la cour
tout le monde surveille tout le monde et
que l'on aurait tôt fait de me cacher
mon affaire non j'ai pensé qu'un
marchand réussira mieux ce tour qu'un
gentilhomme les essayer encore une fois
vous rendre service
mon dieu je lis garçons dans les sectes
taille mince des yeux le troubadour
j'imagine que c'est là le message et si
le roi édouard le voit bourran comme on
le connaît
vous risquez fort de ne jamais revoir ce
jour en saut demain dès l'aube du par
pour l'angleterre oui tu te rends à
londres chez notre cousin albi dit c'est
le fournisseur de la reine isabelle albi
et obtiendra le moyen d'être reçu par la
reine et telus des vivres à mais à elles
seules le message que monseigneur va
écrire mon seigneur je dicte je n'écris
pas
j'ai veillé à n'être point doux et à ce
jeu je connais trop de bons garçons sont
les yeux et la bouche remplie de terre
pour avoir rédigé de leurs mains un
petit billet de trop alors j'évite mets
la signature mon seigneur voici darren
comprendra
attends tour banquiers à mon tour de
quad est d'ouvrir ta bourse ont bien 500
livres c'est un prix d'ami du
monseigneur veux bien me dit-il billet
[Musique]
le pont de nantes
c'est quelque chose par comparaison le
ponte vecchio à florence 1 jouer les
anglais sont gens qui savent recevoir
voilà ce qui vous accueille au gré du
pont une tête
ah oui oui une tête humaine tout
sanglante une manière qu'ont les anglais
de faire connaître aux voyageurs qu'ils
n'arrivent pas dans une ville de
tendresse et de fleurette
la phrase est de notre cousin le signor
albi
qu'importe j'ai là une grande boîte
plate à ferrures de cuivre c'est votre
lettre de créance m'a dit le signor
albite et me voilà c'est en marchant de
bien précieuse confiant notre cousin
albi mais prudent l'édile ed spencer
voyons un peu les bijoux que nous
portent ce jeune italien
et si ce sont vraiment les maires nike
ont dit ces bijoux sont fort beau en
effet mais nous n'en avons que faire
mais les achèteront par madame alors
pourquoi votre beau père m'a t-il pressé
de voir ce marchand pour obliger albi
dit je pense et nous devrons déjà trop à
ces derniers pour acquérir encore je
suis même que votre époux et tous vos
parents avaient si grand souci des
deniers du royaume qu'on pourrait croire
que ce sont les vôtres
mais ici vous tolérez que je dispose de
ma cassette ou à tout le moins de ce que
l'on a laissé
j'imagine que si ces mêmes joyau était
présenté à mon époux et aux vôtres ceci
en trouverait facilement lusage pour
s'emparer l'année l'autre comme aucune
femme n'oserait le faire
madame oui
madame ferez-vous la grâce de considérer
cet anneau et dans remarqué la ciselure
s'il me plaît à voir
avez vous d'autres objets de la même
provenance pour vous servir madame les
prix en sont inscrits ici
quant au niveau de paris aussitôt
qu'elle vous plaira demain leurs données
madame dès lors à monseigneur d'artois
que je me rendrai en france dans les
prochaines semaines et que j'agirais
avec lui comme j'en suis contenu je
dirais aussi à monseigneur d'artois
qu'il vous récompense de notre peine
mieux que je ne peux le faire moi-même
en cet instant
adam l'honneur de vous voir et vous
servirez pour moi la plus belle des
récompenses
je vous fais savoir par albi dit ce que
je déciderai concernant cette bague à
dieu bon je quitte l'angleterre je
galope à travers l'île de france
si j'arrive à neauphle-le-vieux une
vieille créances que mon oncle tolomei
m'avait chargé d'enquêter sur le chemin
du retour
comment mois pousse cheval yoni propre
neveu du chef de la compagnie doit me
dérange en personne pour une créance est
d'abord qu'ils sont si chacun d'eux crée
c'est qu'ils nous doivent 300 livres le
vraiment bon paix à son âme
deux fils que font-ils il chasse c'est
moi qui vais les chasser vous allez voir
combien valeur château leurs chants 800
900 livres bon comment se nomme le
prévôt de montfort portent fruit sa
venue d'on prend un très beau bon je
vais le guérir
je me rends avec lui chez les crécelles
et je fais saisir mon or ou la saisie
telle est ma devise
comment une fille qu'elle va t-elle
c'est 100 et je veux être l'aide à faire
peur comment s'appelle-t-elle narith
pressait
je viens pour affaires mes frères sont
là et ma mère aussi
mais pour l'heure il se trouve forte
[Musique]
non messieurs portent fruit mon grand
père a les pieds nus dans les ruisseaux
chaparder nos pommes aujourd'hui vous
êtes prévost et vous prétendez nous
plier le jeu qu'avez-vous fait d'autre
sinon tendre les pauvres gens tandis que
mon époux se ruinaient pour la guerre du
roi il ne gagnait que meurtri sur le
domaine lui allait comme il pouvait cela
ne nous a pas empêchés de payer la
taille et les aides et l'aumône à dieu
j'accomplis les ordres du roi
non je ne vous crois pas le roi le peu
ordonné de traiter comme des malfaiteurs
des gens qui ont la chevalerie depuis
plus de deux cents années laissez nous
du temps nous paierons par petites
sommes du temps je vous en ai déjà donné
ça n'a servi de rien vous devez encore
au trésor 300 livres où vous payez ou je
saisis et fait vendre
saisissez la famine vendée c'est la mort
les ordonnances sont les ordonnances je
fais y saisir unac ce mot là à la bouche
que lui devez vous juste je ne suis qu'à
réformée de ces choses mais je crois
qu'il s'agit de la taille de mutation
après le trépas de mon père c'est à ce
titre qu'il vous réclame 300 libre oui
et nous lui en avons déjà payé 300 1
oui nous les avons emprunté à un coquin
de banquiers allons bas je crois
mais si après vos wii ne seriez vous pas
un peu en train de voler mais vous êtes
vous il souhaitait ne pas la prendre
d'autres villes si par malchance vos
comptes n'étaient pas justes il se
trouve que j'ai moi aussi quelques
raisons de m'intéresser à l'héritage du
cir de cressé voyant un peu à combien
estimez-vous ce domaine mais je ne
regarde pas moi aussi ça me regarde je
les alpes les nuages n'en fait rien vous
parlez d'un homme qui vola cinq jours
était l'hôte de madame la reine
d'angleterre et qui ici le caprice lui
prend peut faire savoir demain missir
enguerrand de marigny comment se
comporte son prévôt de montfort alors
messi que vous ce domaine je sais porté
à l'estimation du bailliage pour vos
trois mille livres
tiens on estime diablement cher dans
votre bailliage yann était le tout en vo
900 au mieux compte et si l'on parlait à
présent du taux de la taille de mutation
dans votre voyage quatre soldats livre
un compliment
vous mentez gros messire portent fruit
la taille est de deux seuls pour les
nobles en tout bailliage vous êtes de
mon avis il faut recommencer les
contingents bonbons nous disons 900
libre le domaine sont au plus haut les
droits sont deux de sol la livre si je
compte bien tout additionné principal et
intérêts ça ne peut guère dépasser sans
livrer quelques semaines maintenant
disons 100 libre
il convient de messire que vous vous en
rendiez 200 qui ont été encaissés à tort
quoi rendre de l'argent un collecteur
d'impôts mais voulu qu'on s'est bien
porté fruit votre nom bon demain mais si
enguerrand de marigny sera instruit de
votre façon de faire les comptes
une très vilaine façon messire portent
fruit
qu'êtes vous messire voix qui nous
devons tous je m'appelle mucho bayonne
je suis le neveu de la banque tolomei et
je viens pour la créance mais si vous
nous ferez bien l'honneur de partager
notre maigre repas il faut avoir de
biens puissent entrer son pour
entreprendre anoci périlleux voyage
quand on est attendu à la cour
d'angleterre
vous avez vu la reine depuis près que
vous ne vous voit madame isabelle
isabelle de france en personne dans son
privé j'avais un message secret à lui
remettre
[Musique]
marie avait une façon de m'écouter et
les brandt rouverte comme une grenade
mur qui me donnait envie de parler de
parler encore et le lendemain matin
et cette vous
pour cet enfant
[Musique]
4 avril 1314 la date vaut d'être retenu
pour une belle journée c'en est une
ce matin-là à une ou deux milieux en
avant de clairement de l'oise
monseigneur de poitiers second fils du
roi de france et son oncle monseigneur
de valois viennent d'accueillir ou non
du souverain leur soeur et nièces
isabelle d'angleterre ils ne sont pas
les seuls au premier rang regardez les
aumônières oui les frères donné sourit
et mais gentille et en pensant au bond
au sein de vos dame
je gage que vous n'y toucherai plus il
respirait bien le jour qu'il fait c'est
l'un de vos derniers
vous êtes décidément plus belle madame
chaque fois qu'on vous voit mal à moi
cimétière gauthier philippe donnet les
plus loyaux écuyers de votre frère et de
votre oncle voyez madame pour venir vous
accueillir ils ont mis leurs plus belles
parures
ils sont un peu mes protégés
vous tenez toujours dans cette pièce oui
c'est ici à maubuisson que je prends
conseil de moi
mon père
oui
je suis malheureuse
est-ce pour m'informer de ceux ci que
vous avez entrepris ce long voyage
notamment vers qui dirait que je n'ai
pas le bonheur le bonheur donc à bien
vous pris ma fille que le bonheur soit
affaires de roi oui je suis rennes
croyez vous que l'on me traite en reine
là bas ignorez-vous à quel homme vous
m'avez marié je ne vous ai pas mariée à
un homme mais un roi un roi qui
déserteront lit dès le premier jour roy
qui m'a fait un enfant par miracle le
roi qui me fuit comme une lépreuse qui
accorde non pas même à des favorites
mais à des manants les ardeurs dont je
suis privé je ne vous ai point sacrifié
par erreur isabelle s avoue que je dois
apprendre ce que nous devons à nos états
et que nous ne sommes point n'est pour
nous laisser aller ainsi à nos douleurs
de personnes est vrai que vous n'avez
pas de coeur savez vous qu'on vous
appelle le roi de faire quoi vous aussi
le roi de faire
tant mieux si j'ai bien su cacher mes
faiblesses
le pouvoir est une chose à mère isabelle
depuis neuf ans depuis la mort de votre
mère je le paie de solitude et de
rigueur
pourquoi êtes vous venez
mon père alors du tout je suis venu mon
père parce que mes frères ont déposé des
gars que je lis eu et que vous m'avez
appris être comme vous apprend à
défendre l'honneur
connaissez-vous le jeune médecin guti
donnait ils sont deux frères que je
confonds toujours leur père fut avec moi
en flandre
celui dont vous me parlez a épousé une
montmorency il est à mon fils poitiers
comme écuyers et surtout à votre brume
blanche mais de plus galants de façon
quant à son frère philippe quitte à mon
oncle valois celui-là est à marguerittes
marguerite que vous avez choisi pour
être un jour reine de france
marguerite que l'on pourra bientôt
appeler marguerite la [ __ ] vos preuves
isabelle
[Musique]
mais simon gerrans de mardi que je suis
est de devoir j'ai conduit mon frère est
fils vous êtes toujours été plus j'avais
grand désir
oui grand désir d' beaumont comminges
utile d'appeler vos dame vous le voyez
je ne suis point venu seul vous dites
souvent que votre belle soeur ne vous
aime points pourtant je viens
d'apprendre qu'elle vous fait de beaux
présents à mon insu voulez-vous me
montrer ses aumônière que vous avez reçu
d'angleterre
et bien mes filles pourquoi ne répondez
vous pas j'ai laissé mon aumônière à
paris moi de même aussi vous saviez
pourtant que la reine votre belle soeur
venait à maubuisson et vous ne lui avait
pas fait la grâce de les porter puisque
c'est omonia sont à paris quoi de plus
simple nous allons envoyer deux écuyers
les prendre sur le champ aller quérir
mais sir philip et gauthier d'aulnay où
sont dans vos époux dans la salle
d'armes cyr mon père
mon père c'est gentil de me semble avoir
prévenu votre souhait il apporte pendus
à leur ceinture les aumônières que vous
demandiez à voir pouvez-vous me faire
connaître comment ses écuyers se trouve
pourvu des présents que vous avez votre
belle soeur garde roi appelez votre
capitaine messire alain saisissez vous
de ces deux écuyers au cash aurait
offert ils auront à répondre devant la
justice
cyr il suffit c'est un messire de
nogaret que vous devrez parler à présent
les princesses seront gardés ici par vos
hommes jusqu'à nouvel avis défense à
elle de sortir défense à quiconque à
leur servante à leurs parents et même à
leur époux de pénétrer dans cette pièce
où le correspondre avec elle vous me
répondrez
allons messieurs
prions dieu philippe tout est fini
[Musique]
présent je peux bien le dire lors mais
quand j'ai commencé le monter cette
belle machine je tremblais qu'elle ne se
brise a comme les autres
mais cette fois dieu était avec l'artois
est maintenant en selle à paris chez ma
tante mao
je veux que cette chienne tran grâce à
prenne son malheur de ma bouche je veux
qu'elle vient la victoire je veux
qu'elle aide à sa ruine en allant par
air devant le roi et tu sais quoi alors
mais je veux qu'elle en crève de dépit
nous y sommes de nogaret chevalier
secrétaire général du royaume
par la grâce de notre bien-aimé cyr le
roi philippe quatrième avant sur l'ordre
d'icelui wissous la question donnée avec
l'assistance des tourmenteurs de la
prévôté de ladite ville des cirques
authier donnait ateliers de monseigneur
philippe conte de poitiers et philippe
donnet écuyers de monseigneur charles
compte de valois considérant avoir
suffisamment éclairé la cause est la
voix des prisonniers devenant inaudible
nous avons décidé de clore la question
pour en faire rapport au roi
notre site messire guillaume
il nous reste à juger nous allons le
faire
ensuite vous détruire et ceci afin qu'il
n'en demeure traces que dans le secret
de nos mémoires
mon épouse la blanche avec un autre
homme
ensemble mêlée dans les mêmes draps
charles vous avez été un bien faible et
pour fénié au moins en cet instant
d'être un prince sa part le sans dieu il
se passe d'étranges choses dans le
royaume et jusque sous le toit du roi on
a les princes de france occupée à
discourir de vertus comme des paysans de
bourse dont on aurait encore hausser la
femme où se tient ou plutôt tout se
défait de poser ce prix mariniers en
tête n'ont eu de cesse de mettre à bas
le bon droit féodal aidé à genouilly la
chevalerie étendant nous après cela mon
frère qu'il suffise de deux cavaliers
pour culbuter vos brute et faire porter
des cornes à vos fils de ses écuyers
appartient votre hôtel tout comme
l'autre est bachelier de votre fils j'ai
été dupe soit je le paie assez cher
raison de plus pour agir vite et fort il
n'est pire crime de masse al que le rapt
honneur sur la femme de son suzerain te
perdons nous tous se tendre avec ses
frères bourne et considérer les pour
mort mon frère ce qui nous reste à
régler c'est le sort des princesses
adultère par les louis bâtarde
voilà ce qu'on va bientôt dire de ma
fille une bâtarde
il suffit et pourquoi ne pas le crier si
c'est vrai pour éviter qu'on le répète
louis veuillez seulement dire votre
conseil sur le châtiment qu'il faut
réserver à votre épouse pour lui ôte la
vie elle est aux deux autres toutes
trois au nord la mort la mort leur vous
égare jean laforce démérité en servant
les coupables et entreprises de
marguerite ou de blanche
non car elle n'a pas obtenu de preuve
d'une maîtrise faites-la dont tourmenté
par lui et vous verrez si elle n'avoue
pas elle a aidé à souiller mon honneur
et celui de charles
si vous nous aimez vous lui ferez même
hugo deux autres si nous devenions
sérieux oui votre honneur mes chers elle
a compté france ne l'est pas moins
vous avez la navarre en propre qui vous
vient de notre mère vous êtes déjà roi
et vous aurez le plus tard possible à
dieu plaisent la france
la mort de blanche ne vous autres rien
vous êtes juste ici à bon compte
moi je n'ai que poitiers que notre père
m'a donné je ne suis même pas peur de
france tout le reste je le tiens de ge à
ma femme je suis content palatin de
bourgogne et sir de salins dans les
mines de sel produisent le plus gros de
mes revenus
et tout cela par mariage voilà qui
incline à la clémence alors après
conseil de jeunes soient closes dans un
couvent pour le temps que se fasse à
l'oubli mais qu'on n'attende pas sa vie
vous mon frère mon neveu a raison dans
devant dieu que devant le royaume la
mort et choses graves qui nous sera pour
chacun grand tournant et que nous ne
devons pas décidé pour autrui dans la
colère charles mon frère la mort serait
une faute
le couvent un châtiment trop d'où la
forteresse avis les trois
blanche comment at elle pu elle me
répétait sans cesse qu'elle m'aimait
elle me le prouve est elle le prouvait
je jure à l'ats qu'il faut t'il faire de
votre épouse
je ne sais mon père je suis perdu je
veux partir je veux entrer dans un
couvent ton conseil d'isabelle une femme
qui a failli doit être écarté de
transmettre le sens des rois et le
châtiment doit être connu du peuple afin
qu'ils sachent que le crime d'une fille
de roi et punit plus durement que celui
d'une fille de surf c'est bien pensé
justice sera rendue avant vêpres madame
ma tante était pire allez-vous perdu ou
robert à l'entrée prochaine je ne lis
pas ma tante
le moment est mal venu nous sommes dans
la mâture wa loup sauvage grand loup
cruel il faut est-ce que tu manigances
thierry ce que je viens vous annoncer ma
tante était venu à vous seuls
il touche à notre honneur on peut tout
dire devant mon chancelier ils partagent
mes secrets certains ne vont-ils pas
jusqu'à dire qu'ils partagent aussi mon
lit mon neveu a paraît-il à un grave
malheur à nous apprendre hélas battante
nous avons eu ensemble des différents
dieu m'est témoin que je vous ai
souhaité tout le mal possible mais pas
cela pas cela qui touche à l'honneur
viable pour la première fois tu
m'inquiètes il faut que tu sois bien sûr
de ton cou pour faire ainsi durer le
plaisir et bien parles tu meurs dans vie
que je te le demande
ma tante vos filles mes cousines sont
convaincus l'adultère est arrêté sur
l'ordre du roi et marguerite avec elle
khakikat eu cette fable dont moi même ma
tante
ça s'est passé à maubuisson à la nuit
tombée toute la cour n'a été témoin
ont-elles avoué elle je ne sais pas mais
les deux frères données sont en train de
le faire leur place entre les mains de
votre ami nogaret ma tante j'ai fait en
pleine nuit les tillieux de pontoise à
paris
croyez vous encore que ce soit mauvais
sentiment qui m'anime
du manger
[Applaudissements]
les gosses après ce que j'ai fait pour
elle les mariages que je leur ai rangé
ce faire passer comme des ribaudes et
dans quel père de tous qu'on les enferme
qu'on lise opa culpa on l'a fait mais
c'est bien mal vous remercier toute
votre père crever ne joue pas les bonnes
âmes du m&a pas équipés pour sa matrice
a tout entendu n'est ce pas oui madame
j'étais derrière la porte
comme de coutume c'est la nièce de
thierry j'en ai fait ma première
demoiselle de barrage avant elle mes
pieds maintenant elle me surveiller
belle gueule il faut que j'aille à
comtois sur mer l'heure est passée matin
faut que je les voir que vous leur
souffle ce qu'elle voit vraie peau elles
sont au centre de leroy fait un peu
manichéenne et c'est les six chevaux
nous partons sur le champ
depuis quand dureraient ces manèges 4 en
4 avoir fait des filles presque des
rêves avec sa chair son sens sa passion
sa duplicité sahel et tout ça pour quoi
côté écuyers de rencontre les
déshabillent en un tournemain de la
comté france de labarde de la france de
la peyrie que sais-je encore
et les connards les fils du roi qu'est
ce qu'il faisait pour l'instant la 1re
lui va les regarder dans les deux séries
hbo santin joie à mon neveu
comme tu te montre bien on va mordre vif
a tiré à toi rapace est lourd avec des
tripes et du bon sens qu'on gaspille
nous sommes de même race ma tante était
forge pas de rêves mon démo
les blés de marc toiles ne sont pas
encore autres tpr
lesdites marguerite épouse de
monseigneur le roi de navarre et
blanches et push de monseigneur charles
seront emprisonnés dans la forteresse de
château gaillard est ce tu sois louise
arrive à temps
juste quelques affaire de sorcellerie y
ait de sodomie m'apparaît et ce pour le
restant des jours qu'il plaira à dieu de
leur accorder aussi dame jeanne comtesse
palatine de bourgogne épouse de
monseigneur de poitiers étant établi les
complaisance coupable qu'elle eut sera
enfermé dans le donjon de dourdan pour
autant qu'il sera nécessaire à sa
repentance et qu'il plaira aux rois
aussi les cires gonthier et philippe
données ayant forfait à l'honneur et
trahi le lien féodal en commettant
l'adultère avec personne de majesté
royale seront roues et écorché vif
châtrés décapité et pendu au gibet
public de pontoise au matin des jours à
suivre celui ci ainsi notre très sage
très puissant et très aimée roi notre
cyr en a jugé ces chiens qui a tout fait
ce chien
[Musique]
tous
non madame leroy n'autorise que ses fils
s'ils le désirent
cfi seul ça veut pas je ne voulais pas
sa mère natacha que je ne voulais pas
que je les ai toujours rêvé
tim mccord pitié qu'elle n'oublie pas
ciao ciao points de faiblesse au point
de faiblesse à près de pitié ecoutez-la
les plus d'hommes que son frère même
avec nos crânes chauves et les traces
rouges du rasoir
nous sommes attentifs à mme basel elle
n'a pas de travail pas de coeur pas de
st rien de la glace là nous avons
d'achat leur sens elle vous n'auriez
rien appris mais elle vous et comme elle
mais comme elle nous a tous par de
nouveaux crimes il me pardonnera plus
vite mais crime qu'il ne fera de toi une
femme heureuse sur elle et un sceptre un
royaume que je respecte et moi j'ai eu
le printemps
l'amour d'un homme sa chaleur son odeur
sa force c'est bon tu sais un corps de
garçon sur le sien faites la taire
demande à edward que tu as éloigné du
corps des femmes
il sait lui comment ces faits un homme
on est là non il est belle
tu n'as rien à dire investir de
pareilles j'allais déjà commandés je le
recommanderais peut-être de nouveau
quelques jours il souffrira bien encore
une fois de partir mon ordre
l'obv fut lente à venir
d'abord il a fallu nettoyer les sujets
on supplie si propre chez nous un petit
coup de vis ça leur fait mieux battre le
coeur c'est leur collant les jouets puis
en route une heure de beaux spectacles
en échange de deux vies tom qu'est ce
que c'est qu'une vie d'homme l'époque
est rude sacrément rude une femme sur
deux crève en couches deux enfants sur
trois traits passe au berceau
les hivers de famine et les années de
peste est ce que dieu est économe de la
mort roué écorché vif châtre est
décapité je pense que nous avons bien
jugé
et les princesses
elles ont assisté au supplice chacune de
son chariot comme vous l'aviez ordonnée
où va le royaume mes fils n'ont point
d'héritiers filon auront s'ils
reprennent femmes
ils ont femme devant dieu le pape peu
les ont délivré un adultère n'est pas un
motif d'annulation
si je ne puis donc m'en remettre qu'à
d'éventuelles veuvage pour rassurer
m'aligner
que n'avait ou fait exécuter vos brucy
deux tout au moins pour m'aliéner les
deux bourgogne la succession au trône
est certes choses importantes mais rien
n'est davantage que l'unité du royaume
sans nul doute que messire guillaume
vous allez vous rendre auprès du pape
clément vous lui représenterait qu'une
union de roy n'est pas une union
d'hommes ordinaires
j'ai emploi raymond celle ci mais ne
doutez pas que la duchesse de bourgogne
met tout en oeuvre pour nous faire
obstacle au près du saint père le saint
père nous doit tout d'abord ça tient le
moment est venu qu'il s'en souvienne ont
chevauché réussir il semble avoir
parcouru un long chemin de qui vient
at-il je ne distingue pas ses armes
il conviendrait aussi deux chapitres et
monseigneur louis afin qu il n'alla pas
par quelques démarche inopportune gâcher
sa propre affaire j'y veillerai un
messager du carpentrassien ils demandent
à être reçus par vous même
qu'ils viennent le courrier du tap
cyr
le pape clément est mort
[Musique]
le pape que nous avions fait et
maintenant à dieu quand at il passé
voilà six jours francs dans la nuit du
19 au 20
un mois après oui si un mois après
comment est mort notre saint père si le
pape clément était chez son neveu
lorsqu'il fut pris de fièvre et
d'angoise ces physiciens ont tout essayé
jusqu'à lui faire manger de l'émeraude
qui les entoure
mais rien n'y a fait l'étouffement l'a
pris sur la route de guyenne à
roquemaure où il voulait se rendre pour
mourir ses cardinaux et et autour de lui
pas tellement j'évalue des regards et
philippe
non
c'est à comparaître au tribunal que jeff
bock et il serait ourdi jusqu'à la
deuxième génération
[Musique]
la comtesse mahaut cette prise de haine
pour guillaume de nogaret qu'elle
croyait l'artisan de la perte de ses
filles sa demoiselle de parage béatrice
dirso à l'est par moyen de sorcellerie
l'aider à se venger elle connaissait un
ancien templiers soyez la bienvenue
noble dame
jega vous payez la dépense de l'hôtel
d'artois que voilà une bonne action en
un temps où les gens sont si vilainement
méchant pourquoi au sujet de la reine de
navarre et distille ce n'est pas un
amant qu'on lui prête mais 10 mai 50,1
par soirée et le pauvre prince louis
on répète partout confirmé dans le
château de même il tourmente ces
serviteurs pour leur faire avouer ce
qu'ils savent et qu'après on expédie
décor à la scène voyons cela fait quatre
livres 8 sous et 4 deniers pour
l'anecdote j'ai compté six livres vous
voulez sans doute voir votre protégé
mais très grave je vous lâche une petite
heure
tu vois
nos châteaux et domaines commanderie des
chevaliers là vaut tout de même mieux
clame en toi tu vaux mieux que
l'éternité
toi tu m'a recueillie tu te souviens
fuyons la veille d'être brûlée et ma
jambe broyée pour me faire avouer que je
ne mettais consacré au diable ce n'était
pas vrai maintenant c'est vrai qu'il n'a
plus la foi
non
génieau j'ai la haine
le pape clément un de chrome et déjà la
main de dieu rapide
oui mais l'autre vie celui à qui tu dois
t'on pied brisé n'est ce pas ici qu'il
se sert en jambes elle ouais
je sais le moyen de traduction
d'altitude une poudre qu'il suffit de
1000 à la cire pourquoi désir culture
des templiers ne sont pas seuls alors il
ne faut pas tarder le neveu du grand
maître jean de longwy a juré de venger
mais sur deux mollets j'ai reçu un
message je dois me tenir prêt à
rejoindre les autres langues
quand pourrais-je avoir ça tourne
voici la centre celle de la langue d'un
homme que nous garer a fait périr et que
j'ai mise à dessiner dans un four à
minutes pour rappeler le diable j aimais
les du serpent de farah si on respire la
flamme une heure on meurt
bien
c'est peut-être la dernière fois que
nous voulions commencer tu comme tout et
ont plié pour rester chaste
pourquoi te donne tu as noir c'est plus
jeune je ne suis plus beaux les plus
riches et je boite je suis capable de
tout dit quoi
parce que tu es capable d'être débout
disque là ma vie était deux minutes
dominées xi au jeune guillaume viande au
resto in temps d'antenne il ne veut de
l'humanisme est signée coûteuse observé
rich tony dominique oui justin et qui a
voté propice y intéressent et prosterner
m diam's ou stimuler dominé soust inuits
à nîmes à mu
la victime a bien dominé custodia
matutina aux crues yonne look de spera
vite israel in domino qui abdominaux
miséricordieux et copieuse à bout des
roumains comme si les types ses riddims
et israël avec la mort de nogaret
philippe le bel paru avoir pénétré dans
un pays où personne ne pouvaient le
rejoindre
la prophétie du grand maître ne quitte
guère son esprit le printemps réchauffer
la terre et les maisons paris vivait
dans le soleil mais au louvre le roi
était comme exilé dans un univers
intérieur l'été passe à 1,6 puis vint la
journée du 4 novembre
ce jour là disent que tu as vu hier dans
la forêt de pont sainte maxence
pendant la chasse de notre cyr norma
philippe dit le miracle oui eh ben voilà
j'ai vu la croix entre les bois du cerf
une croix d'argent tout scintillant dans
le soleil on les fait que tous les deux
a regardé ça lui et moi lui le roi je
vais reconnu tout de suite
tiens pardi c'est lui qui m'avait a
franchi en même temps que les autres
servent du comté c'est des choses on se
souvient à ça c'est pas ça qui est
important
si c'est important c'est pour ça que je
l'aimais
tremblant comme une feuille qu'ils
étaient nos tirs pas de peur non de
fièvre on aurait dit la croix d'argent
brillait entre les bois du cerf l
aveugle est je le jure à 3 la regarder
la lâcher les rênes
j'ai essayé d'appeler rien rien pas une
parole pas un son
tout d'un coup il est tombé raide vous
pourrez y est comme un arbre croix la
croix
c'était deux branches mortes ici que le
cerf avait accroché dans quelques sous
bois et kijiji vrai louisette au soleil
ramenée pour mourir à fontainebleau où
il était né le roi et rahan lui même
comme un voyageur égaré de la cour la
nouvelle couru les provinces par tout on
eût dit que la france s'agenouillait
devant la grande statue a battu vous
sont mes victoires et le fait qu'il soit
assurée de durée après mois nous avons
fait canonisé mon grand père le roi
louis par le pape boniface
etait-il vraiment un saint un saint est
un bel ornement dans une famille royale
et les juifs
en avons nous pas trop fait brûler ce
sont créature humaine souffrante et
mortelles comme nous dieu ne leur
donnait pas l'oeuvre des cinq puisque le
royaume avait besoin de leurs richesses
rien n'est grand dîner sa part de doute
vous avez baigné grandement la royaume
partagez vous avez fait un pays qui
commence en avoir qu'un seul coeur
partout on crie partout on se plaint du
renchérissement du blé de la modicité
des salaires et ceux qui crient ne
peuvent pas comprendre que ce qu'ils
réclament que je voudrais leur donner
dépend du temps et non de ma volonté ne
me demandez pas de comprendre ce serait
vite d'obéir
le clap j'avais unanime
sauf dans l'ingratitude
soudain un soir philippe le bel éprouva
de nouveau sous le crâne ce terrible
éclatement noir et cette chute dans les
ténèbres qui l'avaient connu dans la
forêt de pont sainte maxence
cette fois quand il rouvrit les yeux il
n'y avait plus ni cern y croit mais une
large forme blanche pencher sur lui non
ai-je dit ma confession oui ici
avant-hier une belle confession qui a
fait notre grande admiration et qui fera
celle de tous vos sujets vous avez
déclaré que vous n'aviez pointe a
imploré pardon des morts que vous avez
ordonné parce que la foi et la justice
se doivent assistance vous êtes repenti
d'avoir arras et votre peuple et surtout
votre sainte église de trop d'impôts
j'ai dit cela
j'ai les 10
oui
pesée louis
ce que c'est que d'être le roi de france
philippe mort on essaya par trois fois
d'abaisser ses paupières
en vain elle se relever d'elle-même ont
dû couvrir d'un bandeau le regard de ce
monarque qui entraient les yeux ouverts
dans l'éternité bâtiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]